justin trudeau ne regrette pas les
interventions qui ont été faites par lui
ou son entourage en faveur du géant
québécois snc lavalin elle était
nécessaire dit il pour préserver des
emplois
mais jusqu'à quel point une condamnation
éventuelle decency lavalas frais
nuisible à l'entreprise
le premier ministre et son entourage
sont restés vagues sur les faits dont
ils disposent là dessus mais nous
espérons que l'économiste daniel denis
nous est claire à ce sujet bonsoir de ce
dimanche soir merci d'être avec nous
alors on l'entend du home hier encore le
secrétaire principal gerald butts le
premier nice par l'idée 9000 emplois des
senseo pays il 3000 au québec et le
reste à l'extérieur jusqu'à l'extérieur
est ce que ce sont tous ces emplois qui
sont menacés on imagine que non non tout
à fait mais ce qui était important de
comprendre c'est que dans le secteur du
génie dans le fond il ya des films de
grande taille et des firmes de moyenne
taille des films de tapi dans le fond
snc et parmi vous demandez grands
joueurs mondiaux si on regardait dans le
fond c'est la plus internationale des
films d'agilité sauvegarde en 2018 dans
les dix
ils étaient situés dans les dix plus
gros joueurs mondiaux et on n'a pas
beaucoup de secteurs des entreprises au
canada même qui espère peuvent se vanter
d'être parmi les dix plus gros et
c'était la deuxième au niveau des
activités internationales la plus
internationale tôt au deuxième rang donc
il faut juste voir que c'est vrai que
c'est pas 9000 emplois puis fait sa
frappe l'imagination actuellement de
véhicules 9000 emplois mais faut voir
qu'il ya quand même un bon nombre
d'emplois qui sont à risque d'aider en
point important dans ce sens suivant
c'est à dire que entre le tiers et 40%
selon les années des activités decency
lavalin sont à l'international
donc ça c'est des personnes qui
travaillent à montréal ce soir au siège
social ou dans une pique aux pratiques
qui peuvent travailler même dans l'ouest
par exemple s'ils sont dans le centre
d'excellence en pétrole qui donne un
soutien à des projets qui se font à
l'extérieur
ces emplois sont d'une certaine façon
harris si snc lavalin pense pas tarder à
la crise pourquoi on voudrait tant
tourner sur ces risques que l'on si snc
est éclaté parce que des possibilités
effectivement c'est qu'on décompose sncc
pour passer à travers la crise actuelle
mais les plus petites organisations
seront pas en mesure d'aller chercher
ces grands comptes mais parce que ça
fait partie des arguments qui sont
véhiculés ici snc éclatait il ya
d'autres entreprises qui pourraient
acheter ces petits bouts la refaire
émerger et dans le faux latin il faut
comprendre que dans les génies la taille
est importante
et puis actuellement dans le fond j'ai
dit les disques en joie sensei parmi les
dire on en compte six entreprises
chinoises deux entreprises américaines
on compte même pas de toute entreprise
européenne actuellement dans les grandes
entreprises de génie mais pourquoi la
taille est importante c'est que non
seulement on fait les travaux de génie
mais supinfo les financer il faut faire
le la conception soit il faut les opérer
en tant que tels ils sont n'a pas la
capacité sera pas une taille suffisante
en a pas des ressources financières qui
sont suffisamment grande
on n'est même pas qualifiés pour les
grands projets complexes
ils sont en dégradé fois c'est sur ça
que d'avoir des grands projets complexes
pourquoi pas plusieurs petits projets
c'est pas aussi créateur d'emplois est
en fait c'est cette info ces données
dans 28 de savoir en tant qu elle allait
peser les plus complexes et succinct
doucement depuis un intrigant dollar
ajouté c'est ce qui permet en parallèle
d'avoir des emplois qui sont encore
mieux rémunérés c'est ce qui permet
aussi avoir des emplois qui sont on
pourrait dire dans ce domaine un peu
comme de recherche et développement se
dire qu'on a dit sand expertise dans des
domaines scène cela venait à descendre
expertise par exemple en métallurgie en
alumine présente l'aluminium faire des
alumineries qui sont faites dans le
monde souvent est celle ci est un des
deux joueurs qui veulent soumissionner
qui peut soumissionner sas est menacé
par une éventuelle condamnation pourrait
pas imaginer cette exceptionnelle
expertise leur reste au canada company
c'est à dire que si elle s'est acheté
par une firme étrangère parce que c'est
c'est difficile de voir qu'une autre
entreprise canadienne que ça chez snc
lavalin donc 7 achetés par une
entreprise étrangère
cette expertise le avec le temps avance
et rodez avait sorti à voir s'en aller
plus près du ciel sur scène c'est reste
cette grosse entité est fait mais c'est
les diviser mon fils elle est divisée
souvent des plus petits de
l'organisation ont pas la capacité de
soumissionner on peut les références
pour pouvoir même déposé des offres de
services
on a les ressources financières non plus
pour développer l'expertisé que ces
projets complexes leur ont besoin et
c'est dans ce sens là que dans le fond
là
la taille est particulièrement important
dans le secteur du génie-conseil et au
canada dans le fond le risque qu'on a
c'est un peu comme dans d'autres
secteurs regarder dans les actions
financières les sociétés d'assurance
beaucoup de ces entreprises de services
on n'a pas de joueurs suffisamment un
groupe au canada pour être un chef de
file dans son domaine
en tout cas on le voit que la caisse de
dès que snc lavalin n'intéresse pas
juste le gouvernement fédéral la caisse
de dépôt et placement est ce qu'on
appelle le bas de laine des québécois
ont investi encore tout récemment acheté
des actions c'est le principal
actionnaire jouer tout à fait c'est le
plus important
donc je pense est important de le dire
ça est bon parce que parmi les choses
que concret on entend du premier
ministre legault redouter que c'est le
siège social 106 laval soit acquise
est ce que peut une entente justement
que la caisse de dépôt qui veut que le
siège social doivent rester ici jusqu'à
la fin 2010 cap
ouais mais je suis heureux
éventuellement si snc lavalin est en
crise c'est on l'a vu dans d'autres
situations où il ya des clauses comme
ceux qui peuvent être levés ce n'est que
pour garder un minimum mais pouvoir
qu'on va aller beaucoup d emplois mais
c'est un savoir-faire d'une certaine
façon c'est un siège social vous l'avez
mentionné
il ya tout près de 500 personnes qui
travaillent au siège social ou dans des
fonctions corporatives et ça et domèce
une compagnie qui étrangères une plus
petite entreprise c'est beaucoup
d'emplois perdus à ces gars là et puis
comme zélé dans le fonds de soutien qui
est donnée aux projets internationaux
fait qu'un fort bien la question
dépenses et pas de 9000 en point mais on
peut penser que c'est facilement 2 3000
emplois qui sont très fragiles dans
l'éventualité où snc lavalin dans le
fond sort pas de la crise actuelle qui a
fait il ya des radars 9000 vient de
tomber à 2 3 me si je vous suis bien
mais c'est vrai que parmi les plus
importants ou s'il en faisait pas et ce
sont aussi leurs familles et se sont
aussi j'imagine peut-être des situations
plus extrêmes un enfant des actionnaires
avides email effectivement les retraités
l'enjeu dans le fond c'est à la fois oui
les en point mais dans tous les pays
industrialisés y existe des accords de
réparation est ce qu'on vend bien
il y en a qui viendra aujourd'hui aux
états unis qui t'a fait en a à tous les
mois et demi les emplois la qualité des
emplois l importance de l'entreprise
dans son secteur industriel mais aussi
il ya plein de choses qui font quatre
offices face et 50 en un an alors qu on
oublie souvent c'est à dire que
l'entreprise faux cachant sa gouvernance
qui des jambes parce que la censure hein
la gouvernance les personnes les
processus elles des sanctions monétaires
via un processus de suivi donc c'est pas
gratuit lors elle n'est pas finie elle
en a pas fini avec la justice là on a
l'impression qu'un accord de réparation
c'est peu probable
comment ce qu'elles pourraient être
sauvées ou autrement cette entreprise
lapointe qui veulent m'en faut voir que
sur le plein son grade
une société publique est donc l écosse
elle une valeur actuellement qui
minimale qu'on pourrait dire parce
qu'elle est un investissement important
dans un projet qui le tout 450 euros qui
vous à peu près la totalité de sa valeur
boursière
aujourd'hui probablement que c'est
difficile pour l'entreprise de dire on
va acquérir snc-lavalin parce qu'on va
avoir toutes les poursuites mais une
fois que les poursuites sont terminées
puis dans le fond là les limiteurs sncb
ni par exemple c'est le cas on en vient
à ce scénario là des contrats fédéraux
sa valeur pourrait être encore plus vers
bande a sévi depuis pour avoir nommé
fission même si la caisse de dépôt à 20%
puis si ce n'est que sa valeur boursière
plus basse la fecq actuellement un peu
aller chercher du financement le coût de
son financement
éventuellement de participer à des gros
projets futurs et elle est déjà
handicapées par la situation qui est que
d'accorder un accord de réparation que
dd tout simplement une entreprise qui
est voyou à certains égards bon là est
accusé de corruption en libye
on l'a vu accuser aussi le dossier du
cuse ya peut-être des accusations qui
seront portées relativement des contrats
au début dans l'eau début du siècle au
début de sa grise années 2000 pour le
pont jacques cartier
c'est une entreprise qui est pas qu est
loin d'être propre elle n'a pas une très
belle image non plus en fait ce geste
est un problème qui s'est posé beaucoup
d'un secteur de la construction et du
génie parce que manceau des poisons
internationaux
dans le fond c'est des grandes
entreprises connues européennes et
américaines ont trempé dans les même
genre de magouille et puis on était dans
le fond sanctionné et ont dû mettre en
place des processus différence que celle
ci a commencé depuis plusieurs années
maintenant avec surtout sa nouvelle
direction
mais si on reporte pas la folie ces
pratiques là dans le fond qu'on reproche
à cette section sont carrément pas
inacceptable mais c'étaient des choses
dans leur milieu quitté cours et
malheureusement c'était la situation à
l'époque ce denis merci beaucoup de nous
avoir éclairé aujourd'hui donc les
eyzies